Where we left off
in the last video,
we were able to figure
out the coordinates of all
of the vertices for this face
right here of the tetrahedron.
And so now we can use those
coordinates to figure out
the coordinates of the center
of that face, which is also
one of the vertices of
the smaller tetrahedron.
When we figure out
that coordinate,
then we can figure
out the distance
between that point
and that point,
or between this
point and this point.
And that will give
us the length of one
of the sides of the
small tetrahedron.
And then we can compare
that to the length
of the large tetrahedron and
get this ratio right over here.
So let's get the
coordinates of that point
or this point right over here.
Let's get the coordinates
of this thing.
To do that, we just have to
take the average of the x, y,
and z-coordinates the
vertices of the face.
Now for x, you
can see, hopefully
maybe you see that this
is sitting on the yz axis.
Actually, let me draw the z-axis
here just for visualization.
So z could go up like
that, and then this
would be the negative z
direction would be going down
like that.
So this is clearly
lying on the zy plane.
But even if you
didn't see that, you
could just average
the x points here.
So we have negative
1 plus 1 plus 0
over 3, which is
going to be 0 over 3.
And then you could
average the y points.
0 plus 0 plus square root of
3 over 3, all of that over 3.
And then you can
average the z points.
Let me do this in
a different color.
Average the z's.
0 plus 0 plus 2 square roots
of 2 over the square root of 3,
all of that over 3.
Now this first coordinate right
over here, clearly just 0.
Second coordinate
over here is going
to be the square root of-- this
is the square root of 3 over 3.
This was hard to read.
Square root of 3
over 3 divided by 3.
So it's the square
root of 3 over 9.
And then we have 2 times
the square root of 2
over the square root
of 3 divided by 3.
So it's going to be 2
times the square root of 2
over 3 times the
square root of 3.
This right here
are the coordinates
for the center of this space
face, this coordinate right
over here.
Now using that, we can
now find the distance
between that point
and that point.
We already know this
point's coordinates.
We already know the
center of the base.
We already know that
right over here.
So let's figure out this
distance or this distance,
the length of a side of
the smaller tetrahedron.
So let's write it.
Let me do it over here.
The length of the side of a
smaller tetrahedron squared
is going to be our difference
in x value squared.
So this has an x value of 0.
This has an x value of 0.
So 0 minus 0 squared plus
the difference in y values.
Square root of 3 over 9
minus square root of 3 over 3
minus-- Square root
of 3 over 3, just
so we have a common
denominator, that's
the same thing as 3
square roots of 3 over 9.
I just wanted to
rewrite it this way so
that I have a common
denominator, squared.
Plus 2 square roots of 2.
It's getting messy because I'm--
plus 2 square roots of 2 over 3
square roots of 3 minus
this guy's z-coordinate.
Well, this guy was
on the xy plane,
so it's minus 0,
minus 0 squared.
So this is going to be equal
to-- let me write it here.
Let me scroll to the
left a little bit
so I have some space.
So we have a length of the
small tetrahedron squared
is going to be equal to-- well,
this is just going to be 0.
This right here is negative
2 times the square root
of 3 over 9 squared.
So negative 2 times the square
root of 3 over 9 squared
is 4 times 3.
Negative 2 times square
root of 3 squared
is going to be 4 times 3
over 9 squared, over 81.
So we did that part
right over here.
We had negative 2 times
square root of 3 over 9.
Square that, you
get this over here.
So that turns into that.
And then this term
right over here,
this is just going to be 2
root 2 over 3 root 3 squared.
So it's going to be plus-- so
this is going to be 4 times
2 over 9 times 3.
Or another way of
saying it, this
is going to be equal
to-- let's see.
Well, the numerator and
denominator are divisible by 3.
So this is the same
thing as 4 over 27.
So this first term is
4 over 27 plus what
we have over here, 4 times 2 is
8 over 27, which is equal to,
which is the same
thing as 12 over 27.
You divide the numerator
and denominator by 3.
This is equal to 4 over 9.
So the length of the small side
squared is equal to 4 over 9.
You take the principal
root on both sides,
positive square root.
We only care about
positive values
because we're talking
about distances.
So the length of
one side is going
to be equal to the
square root of that,
which is going to be 2 over 3.
So this distance right
here, this length right here
is going to be 2/3, or
this length right here
is going to be 2/3.
So what's the ratio of
a length of a big side
to the length of a small side?
So the length of a big side
we already figured out the.
Length of a big side is 2.
This thing is 2.
What's the length
of a small side?
Well, based on all the math
we just did, it is 2/3.
Now before we even
cube it, we can
divide the numerator and
the denominator by 2.
Actually, we can divide the
numerator and the denominator
by 2, so this becomes 1/2 1/3.
And 1 over 1/3 is
the same thing as 3.
So 3 cubed is 27.
Or I could write it
as 27 to 1, since we
want to write it as a ratio.
So when you simplify all this,
you really will just get 27.
But if you want to express
it as a ratio, it is 27 to 1,
the volume of the
big tetrahedron
to the volume of the small.
So that ratio is m over n.
This is equal to m over
n where m and n are
relatively prime
positive integers.
These are definitely
relatively prime.
Their only common factor is 1.
Find m plus n?
So 27 plus 1 is 28,
so our answer is 28.